bevor sie irgendwo bei dem titel denkt
dass ich meine kanal schließen ein
ich muss die freude ganz kurz
unterbrechen ich wollte mich einfach mal
generell bei euch bedanken weil ich habe
die kommentare unter dem letzten video
gesehen und ihr seid die absolut beste
community man sich vorstellen kann und
von daher darf ich euch heute recht
herzlich willkommen heißen zur zweiten
episode vorne
wir befinden uns immer noch auf unserer
kleinen insel hier mit der kohle wie
geht's dir entspannt wir haben auch
immer noch unser kleines schweinchen
ihren staat danke auch der für die
netten worte und das schäfchen hat sich
gerade irgendwo hin papier sind wir
haben allerdings für die heutige episode
extrem viel zu der migranten blöcke
cloud wir haben extrem viel zu tun in
der heutigen folge meinen das war doch
safety ändern oder die haben ganz viele
wie kann es denn sein dass wir auf so
einer kleinen insel warum steht auf
meinem haus dass wir auf so einer kleine
insel so viel hektik immer haben so
viele gegner so viel ich glaube ich habe
alle meine sachen außer hier unten sind
noch irgendwelche reingefallen
ok alles cool ich will endlich den alben
machen von wegen hey wir müssen direkt
in eine höhle und wir müssen vorankommen
und so weiter und so fort aber das
müssen wir halt nun mal ich wollte mich
auf jeden fall noch mal ganz ganz ganz
ganz toll bei euch für die extrem vielen
und extrem lieben kommentare unter dem
ersten teil dieses minecraft projekts
hier von mir bedanken das war wirklich
extrem süß ich habe da wirklich mit ganz
ganz wenig resonanz gerechnet und habe
da wirklich gedacht dass er kommentare
kommen von wegen dann hast du doch auch
war ganz ganz viele von euch hatten
wirklich auch verständnis firma in der
situation für meine lage also es ist
jetzt keine kräftige lage der ich mich
befinde aber ich weiß nicht wie heute
warum sind wir denn plötzlich wieder
eine höhle mit fledermaus
[Musik]
seine krasse kampf den ich je hatte ihr
könnt ihr einmal ganz kurz und so wenig
federlesens gestorben der kav ist du
mich verarschen
schild die da einfach so aber die mag
mich oder meinst der danke danke
die macht wirklich nichts dankeschön
extrem vor ort ein gott was ist denn da
drin ist warner will ich dabei sein
[Musik]
august ein auge drauf jetzt
geländespiele geben wollt ihr mich
verarschen
oh mein gott
[Musik]
dass die schildkröten
mein gott
doch den geräuschen 22 herzen ich habe
keine ahnung was das soll
und warum ich hier jeder rast
aber es ist es ist völlig in ordnung es
ist völlig in ordnung
habt ihr euer denke ich mal kommst du
nicht heute kommt ähnlich hoch er kommt
hier nicht hoch ein halbes herz habe ich
ein halbes herzlichkeit einfach ein
bisschen nach vorbei als zehn stunden
später so dass immer wieder ein
wunderschöner sonnenaufgang hier in
minecraft meine lieben freunde
ich schleiche mich trotzdem noch so ein
bisschen um den mittelpunkt meiner insel
rum weil ich angst habe das jedoch noch
der ein oder andere zombie ist aber
lasst das einfach mal auf euch wirken
lassen
wie schön sieht das aus wie unfassbar
schön ist dieses spiel damit wir heute
zumindest überhaupt irgendwas geschafft
hat ich habe ich ja noch gar nicht
gedrückt
ich werde in der heutigen folge auf
jeden fall noch die ganzen bäume hier
fällen
denn dann haben wir hier erst mal eine
freie fläche und können auf dieser der
rennschlitten skelett das ist halt das
ding die können sich nämlich verstecken
unter den bäumen und dann auch da ist es
und dann gehen die nicht kaputt cook das
verbrennt nicht verbrennt sich erst und
das ist nämlich mein ziel für die
heutige folge dass wir das komplett was
ein [ __ ] du gehst nicht in die koppel
gießen nicht in die luft ich werde in
der heutigen folge auf jeden fall noch
alle bäume fällen außer der natürlich
das ist ja unser lieblingsbaum ich werde
den heutigen folge auf jeden fall alle
bäume abfällen damit erstens sich die
monster darunter nicht mehr verstecken
können wir zweitens einen besseren
überblick über unsere insel haben hat
auch schildkröten und drittens wir ganz
einfach überall fackeln platzieren kann
und ein bisschen übersicht haben um zu
sehen wie zwei kühe
ich war ja der dass wir auf jeden fall
ein bisschen übersicht haben und überall
fackeln platzieren können und das ist so
wichtig damit keine weiteren monster
hier irgendwie sportlern und der nacht
ein bisschen arbeiten können von daher
gehe ich jetzt wirklich einfach mal die
ganze insel entlang und packt überall
fackeln hin aber ich glaube wirklich wir
können hier in 34 folgen alles mal so
ein bisschen ausbessern dann fangen wir
mal so ein bisschen machen alles mal so
ein bisschen schön so dass hier nicht
alles irgendwie zerbombt aussieht hier
sind ja wirklich schon 30 40.000 reaper
in die luft geflogen der baum auf
unserer staaten sieht auch einfach
richtig schön aus
generell finde ich unsere möchte ja die
ist jetzt natürlich ein bisschen blöd
gerade die ansicht aber generell finde
ich alles echt schön
ja ich weiß außer ich so hier eine hin
hier dann noch die nächste reihe die
natürlich auch der vollständigkeit
halber zack zack zack das ist doch der
absolute wahnsinn damit sein kleines
regen verdeck wenn es regnen sollte bis
jetzt auch gar nicht gerechnet haben wir
eine kleine ding zum unterstellen so ein
bisher doch eigentlich wohne ich hier
wer schon schillig bis morgen dann jetzt
würde ich sagen machen wir uns einfach
hier vorne wo der krieg an die luft
geflogen ist und wo wir den feind mit
den spinnen und mit den zombies und so
weiter hatten machen wir uns einfach so
eine kleine farm hin unsere beiden
setzlinge nehmen wir jetzt schon packen
die hierhin laser luca hat den
fortschritt hobbygärtner erzielt
nicht dieses scheiß sonne geht wieder
unter allerdings nutzen wir die zeit zum
ende der folge jetzt wirklich
konstruktiv und produktiv mit
konstruktivität er das eigentlich nichts
zu tun und tragen hier immer noch so ein
bisschen erde ab die wir dann einfach
nehmen können um in der nächsten folge
alles ein bisschen auszubessern und
jetzt müssen wir auch mal schauen wer
alles ausgeleuchtet haben ihr könnt doch
ohnehin hier vorne hier ja auf jeden
fall werden die ecke uns hier rein ist
auch stockfinster ist schon süß aus hier
bei uns da unten muss ich natürlich nur
noch dran denken aber wir können
natürlich ganz viele leute auch einfach
aus den höhlen rauskommen von daher
packe ich hier auf jeden fall noch
fackeln dran bisher funktioniert jetzt
aber wirklich extrem gut mit den fackeln
also mit zombies monstern generell et
cetera haben bisher wirklich in dieser
nacht überhaupt keine probleme bevor ich
die folge allerdings beenden möchte ich
noch kurz die knochen hier reinpacken
bekommt man nämlich knochenmehl und aus
knochen mehr kann ich jetzt einfach so
machen und so machen und so und zack
zack
und dann habe ich das schon gemacht
auf jeden fall kann ich dies jetzt
wieder hierhin pflanzen zack zack kann
wieder das weizenmehl nehmen bzw
knochenmehl hier alles ein bisschen
fertigmachen zack zack zack zack zack
was war ach nee schaut mal so wollen die
mich denn alle verarscht es kommen ja
auch noch aus dem wasser wo kommen wir
her wo kommt ihr denn her du klein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
unsere crews tot
unsere kunst
[Musik]
ihr vater ihr wart das ganze zeit die
ganze zeit die kurse
[Musik]
ich würde an der stelle das heutige
video allerdings auch beenden meine
lieben freunde das schiff hat gar nichts
mehr zu essen frist jetzt schon den
rasen es war zwar eine sehr konstruktive
produktive folge allerdings haben wir
die kuh verloren
wir haben die kuh verloren so wie ich
über die letzten jahre meine crew
verloren habe an der stätte bin ich
allerdings meine lieben freunde wir
sehen uns über morgen pünktlich um 20
uhr wieder bei der dritten folge
minecraft mit luca
[Musik]